for all intents and purposes there are
two americas
i think americans are more divided now
than they were during the civil war
during the civil war they were divided
on this spectacularly important issue of
slavery
but otherwise they were not divided and
now that's a big deal obviously but
still right now
the division is
on every issue we agree
essentially on nothing important
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the host of the dennis prager radio show
the founder of prageru or i should say
the co-founder of prageru and my rabbi
even though he's not really a rabbi
dennis prager welcome back to the reuben
report old friend
there is only one
slight cloud over our being together
again
and that is we are no longer living in
the same city
the same time zone or the same coast
i just want everybody watching to know
i miss dave and i miss david
well
we
dave and david miss you and sue we miss
you a lot we're going to see in a couple
weeks but actually
actually that is the perfect place to
start this conversation
because two days before i officially
left los angeles and when i left you
know it was a quick thing and i was just
out of there i hosted a dinner at my
house with a couple couples just to say
goodbye some of the people who were the
formative people of my years in in los
angeles and you you and sue were there
obviously
and we talked about whether it is right
or just or worthwhile to stay and fight
and when you should know it's time to go
i obviously felt it was time to go um
you have a little you know you have
other obligations and things but why
don't we just start the conversation
there because yeah you're you're there
i'm here and yet we see the world in
such a similar way
and we're living in different coasts in
very different planets right now
i am not staying
this might help
give your
viewers uh
more faith in how committed i am to
honesty
i am not staying for the noble reason of
fighting
i fight every day
i would fight if i were in florida but i
wouldn't be fighting florida i would be
fighting wokism
leftism uh wherever it is
i'm not staying because i think
california is salvageable
at this time i do not think it is
salvageable
people who vote for district attorneys
who will increase death
uh are not salvageable
so
uh i'm here because there are too many
people i adore you two were among them
and you left and i totally understand
why you did
but i founded a synagogue here which
means a great deal to me
every single week i have this
time with people i truly love
i speak at the synagogue i'm sort of the
again the unofficial rabbi
and of course other people i've been
here for 40 years it's a long time you
make a lot of friends
but i'm not here because of the fight
issue
if you want to fight you can fight
anywhere in this country from montana to
california to florida
and i wish everybody did fight
but specifically with regard to
california i'm here because of people by
the way if a lot of the conservatives of
california move
to other states that's great for the
battle against the left
because it increases
the
non-left vote
in those states
the worry is when californians who are
on the left
flee california or flee new york
and then bring the policies that they
fled to the new states
that's sick
well i i can tell you from being here
just for a couple weeks i've mentioned
this on the show almost every day the
people that i'm meeting here who are the
new refugees here they know what they
fled and why they fled so i'm very happy
that's right i'm very very hopeful on
that front but but all right what do you
think let's let's go with that for a
little bit what do you think really is
the future of america if
this mass migration happens if basically
there'll be sort of minorities
like you in california that that will be
fighting the good fight but won't have
political power
and then we'll have places in red states
that may be more aligned with us what
what is the united bond of the united
states of america if this continues in
this direction which to me it has to
actually at this point
for all intents and purposes there are
two americas
i think americans are more divided now
than they were during the civil war
during the civil war they were divided
on this spectacularly important issue of
slavery
but otherwise they were not divided
and now that's a big deal obviously but
still right now
the division is
on every issue we agree
essentially on nothing important
and uh
look the there's a fantasy in me that
all the big cities of the country secede
it's not
geographically possible because you
couldn't have in such a non-contiguous
country but if new york and los angeles
and chicago
and san francisco and seattle and
philadelphia
if they all made their own country and
left the rest of us even with all the
finance that they would take all the
money all the banks
it would be paradisical
for the rest of us
but
uh it's it can't happen because of the
geographical issue
so what has to happen is i think what
you just
painted the the scenario you painted was
of of people coalescing in the states
they agree with
and then what makes us united i mean
does that work i mean this is we're not
united we we're not i mean look i i hate
saying it i love this country
we're not united tell me an issue that
left and right agree on
uh i think if the rest of this podcast
could be spent waiting for you to give
me an answer yeah well there used to
have been a healthy tension let's say
between liberal and conservative or
republican and democrat something like
that now it just doesn't exist it's just
basically back well it doesn't exist
because because they're
we're not fighting liberals we're
fighting leftists
if we were fighting liberals there would
be a united states of america
i mean you were fighting liberals might
be on the other side of you
i'd be on the other side of me
i you know i grew up a liberal democrat
because after all i'm a jew from new
york i went to colombia okay i got all
the credentials of i voted for jimmy
carter which for which i'm still atoning
so i i just wanna i always ask
people who knew me tell me one position
i have now that i didn't have when i was
a liberal democrat and and there's
silence
i haven't changed they've changed would
there maybe be one like so when you were
a liberal democrat you were still
pro-life
and now we're talking oh that's a good
point yeah i i have evolved on abortion
by the way not for religious reasons
yeah but for science reasons
solely
you can't deny it's a human being at a
very early age i mean it's just
people who say follow the science are
are generally lying if they followed the
science they would know that a human is
being killed certainly from the the
heartbeat or or brain waves when they
begin
okay uh that we could argue about
zygotes there's an honorable argument on
both sides
but but not but not in the the end of
the first trimester
so before we go too far we've we've done
the
abortion debate we've done the death
penalty debate people have seen us talk
about all those things but i want to
back up to uh where i started that you
already mentioned because you i do sort
of consider you my rabbi but you are not
technically a rabbi but you do host
these weekly services and i've gone now
for years to the high holiday services
that you host and i think it's for me
really reignited something about belief
and faith and tradition that maybe got
lost a little bit over the last decade
or so
and i found the services to be very
moving you go out of your way not to
talk about politics even though the room
of 500 people on you know yom kippur
services are probably going oh man i
wish well i know for a fact this past
year because it was about five days
before the california recall
and everybody wanted you to say
something but you make a point of not
doing that but you relate
the stories of the bible obviously to
today
could you have been a rabbi in another
life do you consider yourself i mean you
went to rabbinical school right
well i went to yeshiva which is the the
beginning of training to be a rabbi
i i and i continued even after that
look i i i know as much as most rabbis
i i know more than some rabbis
i i my biblical hebrew is superb because
i love grammar
and grammar is the most important part
of understanding these texts even more
important than vocabulary you know if
there's a word that comes up you don't
know you look it up it's no big deal but
grammar
is critical
so yes i thought about being a rabbi and
i realized two problems one
i love being mister
i i uh
i think people
uh in many ways better relate to you as
just one of them
it's a very distinguished title rabbi
but i i want it to just be a mister the
other is if you be if you are ordained a
rabbi
you're ordained by one of the
denominations but i'm not denominational
so it would have pegged me
in a way that i didn't want to be pegged
so i i have i have loved being a mister
but i function
in some ways clearly as a rabbi and i
i'm honored to do that so to that point
one of the things that we've discussed a
bunch privately and i think well you've
certainly discussed it a bunch publicly
um is sort of what's gone on with the
secular american jews that's something
very strange has happened here you've
actually written books that at least
have danced with this um that basically
so many of the purely secular jews
traded in all of the tradition all of
the knowledge etc all of the history
for pure secularism or basically i eat
bagels and i watch seinfeld something
like that and for me to even bring this
topic up is a little bizarre because i
have a big identification with that and
i pretty much watch seinfeld every night
and there are parts of judaism that are
so connected to sense of humor that i
think has kind of kept us around for 5
000 years which seinfeld did a joke
about that too um
but can you talk about that a little bit
because i get this a lot from
evangelicals now because i have so many
evangelicals that like me and they'll be
like dave what's going on with the jews
meaning that they're voting for the
party that's a ge that pretty much hates
them that hates israel
against their economic interests etc
so
uh this obviously is a topic i know a
lot about and thought a lot about
so i have to be briefer if you want me
to expound i will but obviously i could
spend the rest of the podcast just on
this subject
here it is in a nutshell
i have often said jews are the most
religious people in the world
the problem is that for most jews that
religion is not judaism
the religion is secular substitutes for
judaism feminism environmentalism
are two are two examples socialism
marxism
jews are jews
trade in
god-centered bible-centered religion for
no god no bible-centered religions
that's why jews are the founders or the
the or among the leaders of virtually
every one of these movements betty
friedan
was a jew and a marxist
as a perfect example
she and ironically you know i debated
her you wouldn't know this i actually
debated her in my 20s wow there's a
video of it which i can't find but that
actually exists
at one point she walked off the stage
and i couldn't care less i just kept
talking and then she came back
she called me a male chauvinist piglet
and i didn't understand why i didn't
reach the category of pig
i still it has troubled me all these
years but you know god works in his in
his infinite wisdom
one of her children is an orthodox jew
ah there you go
there you go so i just want to explain
when jews leave judaism they don't leave
religion they leave the jewish religion
or they leave traditional judaism and
then they they adopt or found other
movements
that are in their eyes the new religion
from marx to betty friedan
uh to whomever you wish to choose and
it's a tragedy for the jews it's a
tragedy for the world what does that
tell you about just human nature in
terms of belief because i've definitely
come around to this that that my atheist
friends some of whom are your friends
too
uh that they end up believing in
something one way or another i think
that's in essence what you're saying you
can trade all that stuff in for another
set of views but you're going to end up
believing in that and usually it's kind
of worse
the uh the brilliant line on that is is
uh attributed to gk chesterton but i
don't know if there's proof he actually
said it but the guy was so witty he
might have said it and here it is when
people stop believing in god
they don't believe in nothing
they believe in anything
and here's your proof
they believe men give birth
okay
that's the proof of chesterton's line
they don't believe in nothing they
believe in anything
if you're a college graduate today
you not only believe men give birth you
believe that to deny men give birth
is to deny science
you by the way said in essence that on
bill maher you know what basically about
a year ago and the media years ago two
years two and a half years ago was it
that right before covered what a time
warp so
i i it you could you're you you've seen
it but your uh viewers can watch this
it's somewhere on youtube dennis prager
bill maher yeah we'll lay it in
we'll lay the clip in right here so
people get to see it the left wing says
i'll give you gigantic lies that the
united states is a racist country this
this is a lie this is a gargantuan lie
this is the least racist multi-cultural
multi-ethnic country in the history of
the world that these people believe it
is proof to me about how effective lying
this is an unbelievably non-racist
country have you people been to asia
do you people know that the japanese did
not allow one vietnamese boat person
into japan okay because they're not
japanese but we allowed them into
america what is that
no better than the japanese better than
everyone dumb arguments
racist than any country with many races
okay
it is a lie but we could still have
something
documented of course there's i'm a jew
okay there are anti-semites in america
it is a giant lie that america is
anti-semitic i taught jewish history at
brooklyn college i know it i wrote two
books on judaism this is the least
anti-semitic country jews have ever
lived in to say america's anti-semitic
is a lie to say it is racist is a lie
okay these are giant left-wing lies
we're talking about degrees to say that
men can menstruate it's a lie and that
is now that is what is said
wait wait wait wait where did that i
never said you've never heard it right
okay check it out folks check it out i
think anyone
he said oh trump lies trump lies trump
lies said doesn't compare to left lies
what are you talking about dennis well
america's
systemically racist is a gigantic lie
and so is men menstruate
and he just laughed and the audience was
laughing all at me
where the hell did i come up with that
goofy line men menstruate that was just
two and a half years ago
and now he's making fun of the emoji
from apple of the of the uh of the was
it the pregnant man the pregnant man
yeah so what yeah so actually help me as
my as my uh proxy rabbi
one of the things i've been talking
about on the show a lot for the last two
months maybe more than anything else is
my last remaining liberal friends so the
bill maher types who get it on free
speech and they get it on locism and
they get it on critical race theory and
all the stuff but they seem unable to
get to the end of the road which is that
perhaps
liberalism in its modern sense or the
democratic party in its modern sense or
some version of those things is what led
to all of this and they might have to
vote for you scary religious republicans
what do i do with these people i want to
be open but i also want to get them to
the end of it okay
you are so right so here is my story and
this will answer
your question thank you thank you
for solving this one for me yep yep no
but it's not gonna they're not gonna be
happy here here it is
so i grew up an orthodox jew and i'm
still i'm still quite observant but not
fully orthodox
and i of course kept kosher
uh in
for all of my youth
then when i was in england
uh in for my junior year i figured it
wouldn't hurt my parents feelings and i
violated every ritual law in judaism
because i didn't want to observe out of
habit but out of conviction
and then i came back to many of them so
that for much of that year i didn't keep
kosher at all
and i remember this is what i i want to
tell you what this has to do with your
question
so i i remember the first time i ate ham
and it was it was a somewhat emotionally
jolting experience
now
fast forward
i also remember the first time i voted
republican
i want you to know
that that was tougher emotionally than
the first time i ate ham
i thought i was betraying everything
good that i had ever learned
i had gone over to the dark side
by voting republican that is how deep
the belief in liberals forget leftists
is
that as bad as the left is i can't vote
republican
the the
toxicity of the message
that the danger is on the right
has been so effective
that bill maher could never vote
republican
i look you may be right and you're
probably more of a realist and maybe i'm
still a little bit of a dreamer but i'm
going to work hard on getting the guy to
move oh i don't know we have to work he
who saves one life is considered to have
saved the whole world by the way my
friend i don't know if you've ever seen
any of these videos on prageru but there
was a guy
very handsome guy by the way who did a
video that was all about people
leaving the political closet you might
find that one interesting very handsome
guy beard i don't remember him as that
interesting i i i it's funny i i we have
some handsome presenters
anyway you could go we'll we'll send you
the whole catalog you'll dig it um all
right i want to talk about covet a
little bit because i went with you
in october
of 2020 a month before the election
i said to you dennis you got to come
with me to one of these trump rallies in
beverly hills i had gone the week before
by accident i had driven past one after
breakfast and i said i'm just going to
walk in there and see what happens it
was the most joyous spectacular thing i
had ever seen at a political
in from a political perspective at least
and i and i called you the next day i
said dennis you got to come this thing
we go to this thing this is that you
know still at the peak of covert or
whatever you want to call it there's
thousands of people
smiling happy dancing singing joyous and
as we're walking to uh santa monica
boulevard we had to park a couple blocks
away you said to me and neither one of
us were vax you said to me you know what
it would probably be good if i got kovit
here that's what you said
uh you then did get coveted about a year
later and were
attacked in the most
vile ways on twitter and everywhere else
for getting coveted while not vaxxed
i think you see where i'm going with
this can you just lay out what your
story was on all of this and i also want
to give you credit actually i'm doing
too much talking as the interviewer but
i'll give you i want to give you credit
on saying uh you said back in april of
2020 which is now almost two years ago
your exact quote related to lockdowns
quote the worldwide lockdowns are the
greatest mistake in human history that's
what you said basically two years ago
about all this nonsense then we walk
into a rally
and you were prepared to get covered you
didn't get it there he ended up getting
it about a year later
longest question i've ever set up take
it away
no i i no
don't in any way be apologetic i love
listening to you anyway but
okay there are two separate issues
they're related uh one is what i i'm
very proud of the fact
because it took i have to admit but you
you're courageous yourself so you know
this
and that's the greatest compliment i
could offer you're all so handsome i was
kidding about the video
they're looking pretty good i don't know
i don't know i don't know didn't you you
lost a little weight you look good
i look good i don't know if i lost
weight okay thank you
uh by the way i hate being told i look
good because i heard many years ago this
great line
there are three ages in life
youth
middle age and you're looking great
so every time somebody says i'm looking
good or looking great i go oh crap
it's better than the alternative my
friend yes right well you don't look so
good there i i acknowledge that yeah
and anyway so yes so uh it took some
courage to say
uh in the second month of the lockdown
it was the greatest mistake in history i
made clear i was saying the greatest
evil
there are so many evils that
that dwarf this but in terms of mistake
there's nothing comparable it turned out
by the way to produce some evil but
still it's still the greatest mistake
i was right
while what has been done to children
around the world uh is a form of child
abuse the likes of which we have not
seen except on individual levels we have
not seen communal child abuse
like we have now
masking five-year-olds and two-year-olds
on airplanes i'm asking the kids
outdoors at recess
not allowing them to go to school in
many cases for nearly two years and when
they go to be masked this is all been
a form of child abuse while we have done
to small businesses and made the the
wealthiest scum unbelievably rich like
the tech giants all we've done is
transferred wealth the lockdowns have
transferred wealth from the middle class
to the ridiculously upper class that's
all it is done economically needless to
say what we have done with in terms of
inflation everything about the lockdown
has been disgusting and they didn't work
that's the irony they didn't work and
any american who cares at all about
truth knows that the states that lock
down did know better than the states
that did not lock down we had a real
experiment here not one child not one in
child child in sweden
died and they kept their schools open
all of the
pandemic they didn't close them for a
day kids didn't wear masks why didn't
people use that as a lesson i don't know
because people don't follow science they
follow fear
so i was right and i and i say
periodically on my show i've been right
on virtually every important issue for
40 years this is not a brag it's either
true or not true yes it is true and why
is it true
because i'm only committed to what is
true
i don't have any other agenda what is
true that's why i can't be a leftist
because truth is not a left-wing value
it's a liberal value it's a conservative
value it's not a left-wing value that's
why the left suppresses dissent
truth is pravda it is what the communist
party says is true true pravda means
truth
as regards my own as regarding as
regards my own uh covid
yes i believed that from the beginning
or nearly the beginning i studied this a
lot it is better to have natural
immunity than anything else and i did
not believe i would die from covid i
didn't believe i would die from covid
because i was taking hydroxychloroquine
and zinc vitamin d and ivermectin for
the in for the entire year or year and a
half and i believed that it would
it would ensure
that i would have a mild case and i got
delta the tougher one and nothing
happened i i was i got chills for about
three days i lost taste for half a day
that was the worst part cheese tasted
like plastic
and then i broadcast three days later
so i i was right
uh by the way just one horrible thought
harvey rich of yale of yale a school of
public health epidemiologist
said on my show about half a year ago
that american doctors american
medical institutions have probably
killed hundreds of thousands of
americans by denying them therapeutics i
believe that to be true
what my view of american medical
institutions and many doctors
has gone 180 degrees doctors saved my
life i will always be thankful to them
uh they my surgeries were 100 successful
on my back and on my on my neck and and
i've been i've been great
uh so i'm very grateful to them
but i uh at the same time they are
responsible i think harvey rich is right
for hundreds of thousands of deaths
because of their unscientific irrational
opposition
to uh to therapeutics such as ivermectin
and hydroxychloroquine
so i don't know
that you've said this publicly but a few
days after you had kovid sue called me
and she said you're not going to believe
this who's your wife she said you're not
going to believe this but dennis woke up
in the midst of covet in the middle of
the night in the sweat and he turned to
me in bed and said the davids meaning me
and david
are moving from california it was before
we had announced we were moving to
california
you had some sort of premonition in the
midst of covid what do you make of that
well what do you make of the fact that
i'd wake up in the middle of the night
with povet and say that to my wife i
mean i'm blown away
you were in covent mania and you had a
presentation well i guess so
it also shows you how much i knew i
would miss you guys i i just want you to
know
we're very close i let your your viewers
are are free to know that
they can judge us accordingly what do we
do uh this is what i went on a crazy
rant on my show this morning and i don't
do the rant that often right i'm a
pretty measured guy but what do we do
to the people that got us here and the
people that are still dragging us into
these seemingly endless uh this endless
pit of hell the kathy hoechel in new
york the eric garcetti who holds his
breath when he takes pictures uh gavin
newsom you you know all the people the
people who are still doing it uh despite
no scientific evidence
do we need to have some kind of
nuremberg trials what i mean should they
be just banned from public office like
what would a healthy society do and i
guess i mean this not only at a
political level but for you also out of
either philosophical or a spiritual
level it doesn't seem to me that if
we're ever going to really heal from
this thing we can just move past it like
we're in the phase now where we're
moving past it because the democrats are
realizing they're going to get crushed
in the midterms but we need to remember
what these people did what what would a
healthy society do
uh in this greatest mistake of all time
as well right
by the way you uh you hit the nail on
the head with your line
your penultimate line
of we need to remember so i was saying
on my radio show today
because there's a big recall for george
gascon yeah the ev the evil evil [ __ ]
who is the uh evil fool not [ __ ]
who was the district attorney
and the recall campaign against him last
year in l.a in l.a
in l.a he's the district attorney he's
just like the one in uh in philadelphia
san francisco these are the george soros
funded people
whose a sole agenda is to increase
murder
in the cities in which they work that is
their that is their agenda i truly
believe that by the way now if you said
to them do you want to increase murder
they would say no we want to decrease
the imprisoned
but they're the same thing
okay there it's
it's it's like
you can't have
hot snow
you can't have less imprisonment and
less murder
it's just i'm sorry but uh uh adults
actually you don't have to be an adult a
five-year-old would understand that
before they go to college they
understand a lot more about life
so i said it's interesting they probably
will recall gascon now because of the
murder rate in los angeles
and
this is what people do
they elect the left this is the history
of latin america for example they elect
the left the left destroys their
freedoms their country and their economy
and then they put the right in power
which fixes things up to a certain
degree
or or more than a certain degree and
then they think ah we need more equity
and then they re-elect the left and it's
all a cycle people will not remember
what the left did to destroy this
country uh two years after uh the the
the
the right fixes it up look at how trump
fixed this country
i just had jason riley on he's the the
brilliant black writer for the wall
street journal and he writes he wrote
this book the black boom
and the guy can't stand trump but he
also loves truth more than he can't
stand trump so he writes a book about
how good the economy was for blacks
unprecedentedly good
but do people care no they don't care
the people who claim to care about
blacks voted for biden who's ruining
things for blacks and for whites and
hispanics and everybody else the the man
is a bad man and a disaster the worst
human being to ever be elected president
in my opinion as a human being i think
trump is saintly compared to uh
to biden
so uh this is what there is no memory
that is that's the long answer to your
short question there is no memory people
don't remember what the left did they
don't remember listen
the stalin is popular in russia
the man who murdered 20 to 40 million
russians or and ukrainian soviet
citizens
is popular in russia
mao is popular in china he killed 60
million chinese now for every one of
those whom he killed think of the the
ripple effect of the people whose lives
were ruined because of that death and
he's popular his picture is ubiquitous
in china
people don't remember left-wing evil
they only remember right-wing evil so so
if we accept that and i do i accept that
people don't remember and i accept that
these things are cyclical and the left
ruins things and then the right fixes it
you know i come from new york they're in
new york city david dinkins demolished
progressive lefty demolished new york
city who had to fix it scary rudy
giuliani uh
scary and air quotes obviously um but
okay but putting aside that that we
accept that what could in your perfect
world what would we do to to break that
cycle i mean what what would a healthy
society not what we're in right now what
would a healthy society do so that we
would not forget so we could break that
cycle
there are many answers to that question
dave
first uh the first thing that came to my
mind may not be the first thing to do
but the first thing that came to my mind
is take your kids out of school
homeschool your children
uh that that is the greatest single good
i can think of
to demolish the evil that the left has
become
and
uh because the roots of it are all in
education
for all of my career i have had this
lying dave i'll take a call
and somebody will say something i
consider particularly stupid
and i will then say
in my deadpan manner sir i'm just
curious what college did you go to
and
you know i've really set him up because
he'll then say what makes you say i went
to college
which prepares me for my prepared line
and that is because only someone who
went to college would say something that
stupid
and the the only exception to that is
graduate school you become even more
stupid do you know that the new york
times even published uh that uh with
graduate school then i'll come back to
what we can do in graduate school as you
get more educated you are more fearful
of covet
in other words everything
yeah
i'm sorry yeah how much more info do you
need it the proof is in the pudding they
make people the proof is in the pudding
that's right
every awful thing
increases
as you get more educated now not real
educated be i love crazy about education
i but if if you love education you must
hate most of american schools so the
first thing i think about what to do
take your kids out of the schools
that defunds the schools not defund the
police defund the schools take the money
and give it to parents to do what they
want with it to educate their children
so that that was one all right so you
but you're really asking if i have it
correctly
uh
is what do we do about the bad guys yeah
frankly
continue to do it
correct
uh uh i am i am only interested in
defeating them not punishing them
not that you're wrong
[Music]
i've actually done a show because i've
i've done this i've done an hour on
every i did an hour on women's shoes i
care about everything i mean i really
don't care about women's shoes but i was
curious why women do
so
i know
i'm sorry you love those jimmy choos
that was the only women's shoe i could
think of someone give me a oh okay i
don't even know that one okay you're one
ahead of me
so uh i i did an hour
uh on what what do you emotionally get
more satisfaction from rewarding good
people
or punishing bad people
that's how my brain works and anyway i'm
with you i get more pleasure out of
punishing bad people than rewarding good
people well i'm not sure that's my
position i just think these people have
to be punished to some degree
i hope good people
do too you're right but that that that's
sort of uh
it's it's almost utopian all we have to
do is defeat them yeah okay whether they
lead a miserable life afterwards or not
uh is of interest to me but not nearly
as much as defeating them that that's
what matters to me the most uh some i
mean george soros i think god will
punish him so i actually i get some i
get immense not some immense peace
from my belief that a good god governs
the universe
because they there's so much evil in
this world
that
uh that and it bothers me that there is
so much
that belief that god ultimately makes
things right
in the next in the next world and the
afterlife gives me tremendous solace i
think soros will will be punished the
ban
is is diabolical
uh and i mean it literally diabolical i
don't even believe in the devil and i
think he's diabolical
that's uh what we'd call a condemnation
um i want to back up to something you
mentioned a few moments ago it is you
said uh the new york times so let's talk
about the new york times and mainstream
media for a minute because i'm i'm 45
years old you've got a couple years on
me and for
from where i'm sitting it seems that
in the last
10 years mainstream media corporate
press whatever you want to call it that
it's it's just become nothing other than
lies
and nonsense and obfuscation of truth
and almost complete 180 of reality on
almost every important issue period and
you know they defend democrats and
republicans are always racist okay fine
a lot of people say to me well david
it's always been like this now my my new
conservative audience will say dave this
is what we were screaming about in 1980.
um do you think it's always been like
this is there some new version of it
because now we can expose it thanks to
internet video clips and that we can see
when they chop the word not off the
beginning of a sentence or something
like that or or is just this is this the
same old game that they've been playing
maybe since the 50s maybe maybe since tv
news really started
60s
my
my belief is that
they were always
biased
but that
the level
of
lying
the level
of editorializing in newspape in news
pieces
the crackpots that they published on the
opinion page i mean james reston was
their 60s 70s maybe 80s giant
he was a pure liberal
i didn't particularly care for his
columns
but they would be considered today
centrist
when when when i read charles m blow
uh uh who
uh
all he does i mean i i don't i i wonder
if he spends more than an hour on any
column i wonder if he spends a half hour
on many
there
uh during the trump era
it was all about uh how horrible trump
was it's fascinating do you know that i
made i just cursorily i went through
charles and blow columns and i took out
adjectives that he used to describe
donald trump
and i came out with about 30 and that
was just looking you know cursorily
through a number of them the level of
of evil and and morin hood mor moronity
uh which is probably owned by uh by uh
uh paul krugman
uh
who is
no he's just a vicious idiot uh
he's it gives a bad name to the nobel
prize in economics that that he won one
but i'm not a nobel prize fan
outside of the sciences anyway but
uh
anyway long story short it was always
like this the the reporting from vietnam
was biased as an example
uh of course they they they completely
downplayed the holocaust
uh during the holocaust that's one of it
they're they're well-known things they
completely
they denied they didn't even downplay
they denied that there was a famine in
ukraine
induced by stalin to
murder uh genocidally six about six
million ukrainians starved to death in a
couple of years 1932 or 1934 or 31 to 33
whatever it was
and
they they denied it
they they literally denied their
reporter james durante put up in a
beautiful apartment by stalin and
supplied with the luxuries of life
the guy denied it
denied what was happening in ukraine
so it's not new but it's far far worse
do you know they fired their editor
their longtime opinion page editor
because he invited a republican senator
to write a piece
yes i do know and
here we are they they don't have an
ombudsman anymore right i mean they have
nobody regulating oh that's interesting
i didn't know that i don't think they do
there's nobody regulating the paper
anymore
that's right yeah so
you know who's regulating the paper 30
25 year old 30 year old woke women
so what do we do do we have to this will
sort of get us to the big tech part that
i want to discuss with you as well
but do we just have to build all new
everything and i'm talking everything
from our generators to our tech
solutions
to our
construction workers to our banks
well i don't know about janitors and
construction workers because i think
most certainly the construction workers
are probably
uh more sophisticated in their
understanding of life than most harvard
professors and i mean that literally
yeah i never engage in hyperbole
i i think that buckley's comment about
you know rather be governed by the first
thousand names in the boston phone book
than a thousand harvard professors
is is an entirely accurate one but no we
have to change we have to create our own
institutions
that's what we have to exchange
yes uh look uh in in its way i would i
say with a completely straight face i
would be happy to be put on a lie
detector to test my my honesty on this
matter the vast majority of people if
they don't have their child studying
stem
science technology engineering or math
would do infinitely better having their
kid
watch prageru videos and write
uh their uh an essay on each one and
read the the bibliography that
accompanies the videos then go to
princeton but dennis dennis i've seen
the critics
and they say that they put a you at the
end of his last name and they're
pretending to be a university
what are you doing
yes we're we're teaching people
facts and about life we're giving the
most important thing in life wisdom
facts are easy to transmit wisdom is a
challenge
the uh
you know i'm
i'm having my passover service
the rash i've been
i've been working as you know on the
rational bible the third of five volumes
is coming out
for christmas
and it's the best-selling bible
commentary in america i'm proud to say
costco ordered 35 000 copies of
deuteronomy how's that for an
achievement yeah that's not
that that's a big deal i have to say i'm
very proud of that
because i don't know who at costco could
spell deuteronomy yeah it's not meant as
an insult it's just meant as a fact of
life the e and the u get confusing
the e and the ul you the fact that you
even knew that is
shows you how much reading you've been
doing
in the scriptures as they say
anyway so i i have i i departed for a
year because of covet because they
delayed
the bible commentary i did a commentary
on the oldest holiday in the world
passover it's literally the oldest
holiday and the most important it is the
most important holiday in in human
history
uh for many many reasons and christians
will relate to it because the last
supper was a passover seder
so i'm explaining it in the rational
passover haggadah
is the the hebrew name for the service
and uh
this is
uh my way of of bringing these ideas
uh to to more people
so
uh
back to your institutions about
substituting for institutions
uh
we need to create
a brand new look the religions failed
my my column my latest column is on the
failure of america's religions in covet
how rabbi's priests and ministers went
like sheep
they they just yes yes government
whatever you say government oh there's
no reason for our people to show up for
services it's much more important to
keep social distancing
i mean uh
if you can't look to rabbi's priest and
ministers for courage
and and dissent from irrational
governmental orders
we're in trouble
and we are in trouble i have to say
that's partly why going to the services
that you've held these i've you've been
doing it for years but you know i've
gone for the last five or six years or
something um that's why it's been so
important because even even last year
uh which was still in the middle of
covent and you guys left
400 people you wanted to wear a mask
fine 99 of the people didn't nobody got
sick and everybody got inspired which is
a very good thing for your health
you think you think a little inspiration
is good for the health you think yeah i
mean i tend to think that you shouldn't
you shouldn't just be fearful all the
time and and live in a place where
there's zero risk or something like that
so
so listen to this this is awesome
if you're not if you don't walk around
scared you have left the left
think i mean it literally i mean that
literally there look at they believe the
world is coming to an end it's remember
there it's their word existential threat
of global warming
existential that means of the existence
that these are scared people kovid will
kill them will kill their five-year-old
how fast can i get my child vaccinated
michelle goldberg new york times
columnist she was counting the days till
that she could inoculate her kids even
though kids don't die of covet only only
overwhelmingly old people overwhelmingly
do you think it would have been
completely flipped if if trump had won
if trump was the president for these
last two years and had been saying the
exact same things as biden and fauci was
saying the exact same things and and all
the mandates and all that do you think
it would just be completely flipped and
all of the lefties now
who are completely four mandates but
they'd be saying well it was hitler
pushing the mandate they'd all be
anti-facts right i mean is it that
simple really in some no that is the one
that in that case
uh we had an experiment of that for one
year look he's the one
you know warp speed for getting the
vaccine but he didn't do mandates that's
the difference he didn't do no oh yes
that is oh so you mean had he done
manchester united he done mandates yeah
oh that's very interesting i don't know
i'll tell you why the uh the the
question is
for a leftist what is a more powerful
force hatred of trump or fear of covet
and i believe i have come
this is perfect set up for me to make
this point
uh i thought until the last two years
that the most powerful drives in the
human being
were love and hate
and i now have uh have reconsidered i
believe it is fear i think fear is more
powerful than love and more powerful
than hate so i think fear of covid would
have trumped hatred of trump
all right so let's talk about fear for a
second because one time i asked you i
think we discussed this publicly once
before but it's worth mentioning again
because you just brought up fear
right when i started getting a little
more popular or when the why i left the
last video came out and i was suddenly
getting hate for the first time just
endless amounts of hate online from the
supposedly tolerant people
i i got a few death threats and people
were saying all sorts of mean things to
me and i was worried about
you know when i walked out of my house
like i just was
and uh
i said to you one day i said dennis uh
what do you do about security
and you this is exactly what you said to
me you said dave
you know i've done my radio show from
the same studio for the last 25 years or
something and i suppose one day i could
be walking out and someone will be there
with the machete but when it's your time
to go it's your time to go
and then you laughed and i laughed and i
know you meant it and i know you would
prefer not to be decapitated
but i think that illustrates exactly
what you're saying about fear you don't
have fear related to this but i don't
think it's because
you're uh
magical i think it's because of
everything else you're laying out here
related maybe to belief or your feeling
about humanity etc etc
you know it's really interesting because
the the left's
perfect president was franklin roosevelt
and it was he who said in the 1930s the
only thing we have to fear is fear
itself is a great line
note that it's never excited
never ever cited by even liberals
they find that to be a republican line
the only thing we have to fear is fear
itself
so
by the way it is a
it shows you how america has changed
that a democrat the most liberal
democrat to hold office prior to barack
obama would say
that the only thing we have to fear is
fear itself
and
that now is regarded as right wing
propaganda
that line
if you went on a college campus and said
who said this
and say was it a republican or a
democrat every single person would say
it was a republican
that's that gives you an idea of the
deterioration of the moral backbone of
the american people
fear is now kosher fear
teachers the most frightened group in in
america among the very frightened they
hold uh number one they're gonna die
from a student who is unmasked these
people are out of their minds in fear i
feel for them i don't know if they sleep
at night
i don't walk around with any fear the
only thing i fear
ironically is the left
that's the only thing i fear they will
ruin my life they will ruin the greatest
experiment in liberty they are trying to
do that
and they and they are thus far they are
on the road to success however
not enough because there's you and
there's bee and there are plenty of us
around thank god
this alternate media where there's so
much more truth and wisdom than in
mainstream media is their nemesis
and they would love to shut us down
and that's why we have to seek other
channels like like uh sub stack what uh
not uh what is their what's the name
substance rumble locals there's plenty
yeah
i was right yeah rumble exactly so uh
this is this
and talk radio i mean you know
people
always mention in their right to mention
all these other wonderful things daily
wire prageru
uh um tpusa there are a lot of great
things plus podcasts like yours and
others at jordan peterson your you know
your your your dear friend and and
man i deeply deeply love
uh but talk radio
that's gigantic
you know when i have a all of my career
when i've had european conservatives on
my show
i have ended the interview by saying
this you know what the big difference is
between europe and america and why we
are have such a more advanced
conservatism here
talk radio you have no talk radio it's
all government radio and every one of
them said that is correct
it's all government canada is all
government canada doesn't have talk
radio our neighborhood of the north and
look at how canadians as i said in one
of my broadcasts they should remove the
maple leaf and put a sheep
well they're fighting right now we'll
see which way some are and i'll tell you
the canadian truckers may go down in
history
wouldn't that be something if a bunch of
canadian truckers were the people that
is it would be beautiful
dennis you know you said uh this is
going to be the last thing and then
we're going to keep you for one more set
we're going to do a special segment on
locals only because i have the real
question i've been wanting to get to
we're going to put on local this was all
the first hour of fluff but you said
that you fear only the left i feel i can
come up with one other thing that you
fear
you fear a bad cigar i feel like you
actually would be or
or a bad
uh two things bad cigar
and bad audio connection as you were
listening to a symphony i think that
would be fear not just anger but it
would be actual fear because you love
those things so much
uh that's more in the realm of hate
goodnight everybody
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell